is a movie adaptation of the game gears
of war finally about to be announced
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
a live-action adaptation of the game
gears of war has been planned for over a
decade new line cinema actually bought
the right studios back in 2017 they had
a director they had a writer they had
everything lined up but it just never
happened but now producer dylan clark
who has signed on to produce this movie
has announced that you can expect some
concrete updates very very soon so he
seems to be teasing here that we are
actually finally going to get a gears of
war movie and i'm not even remotely
surprised this is a movie that like i
said they've been trying to make for 10
years that they've got a ready-made
audience for and let's be honest after
the recent excessive uncharted games
being made into movies is going to
become a big thing again
now we've had obviously over the years
games turned into movies some with a
little bit of success tomb raider is
actually quite a good series of movies i
always quite liked him and to be honest
some people could argue it made angelina
jolie's career
and some have been awful
super mario brothers was awful
the
street fighter film was jean-claude van
damme and kylie minogue and everything
genuinely was painful to watch i mean it
was it was it was really difficult to
watch
and the mortal kombat couple of movies
the first one with um christopher
lambert was was okay i love the
soundtrack for it the second one was
pretty bad the the new reboot i could
from last year
was okay
pretty gory um i thought the end was a
bit weak but actually generally it's not
a bad film and they are going to make a
second the resident evil series has
always been really successful and and
not actually a bad series of movies and
i actually really enjoyed the doom with
the boy and the rock johnson um from a
few years ago actually that's not a bad
sci-fi movie and other than the scene
where they have they're looking down the
gun in the they basically tried to
replicate the video game i wish they
hadn't done that and
it's not a bad film at that point i make
about batter scene in doom where they
did replicate the game
really is a sore thumb in the movie
the rest of the film is pretty good but
that bit really stood out as poor now i
don't know why they felt they needed to
do that you get this sometimes in movies
where they feel like they have to give a
nod to the original i remember the
thunderbirds movie from a few years ago
directed by jonathan frakes he should
have been kicked repeatedly in the balls
for this film because i was actually
really excited about thunderbirds movie
and they just completely screwed it up
from beginning to end but in one scene
one of the the the brains basically has
a as a microchip stuck in his back and
he starts walking around like that and
sort of thing like he's a puppet
it was a nod back to the original and it
was supposed to be funny but it was just
bad and a bit stupid
with gears of war if they can avoid that
sort of thing and actually just try to
make a movie inspired by a game i don't
have any problem with this and i think
it could be something that's quite
interesting but who can actually be
appearing in this well it looks like
they've already basically got an
a-lister lined up dave bautista has
actually already in a collider interview
in a few other interviews talked about
this
he talked a couple of years ago now
about how they tried to get him into the
fast and the furious movies he actually
had a conversation at warner brothers
and he basically said nah i'm not
interested i don't want to do a fast and
furious movie but if you want to talk
about marcus phoenix a character from
gears of war then i'm all ears
he has made no secret of the fact that
he would love to make a movie around
this franchise and to be honest you
could so see him in the main character
role it wouldn't be difficult at all he
could be awesome
so basically i would say that the films
that are based around video games have
really been a mixed bag they've never
quite been taken seriously but as i say
with the success recently uncharted that
seems to be changing
now we have had serious movies made
around this before like i said the tomb
raider series is probably the main
example of that being done right if
these movies are done or the similar
sort of vein where they just try to make
a film inspired by the game and don't do
the silly nod back to it or try to
replicate the game in a movie then this
could be something really interesting
but there's also other news they
recently did a poll and they asked
gamers what do you want to see turned
into a movie which one of your favorite
games do you want to see on the big
screen and the winner by quite a
distance actually
zelda
now that is a film that i really am a
bit worried about
because they would really have to try to
figure out some way of it not being lord
of the ringsy there's been quite a few
zelda games they would actually have
quite a lot of story to pick from if
they do a tomb raider version of this or
they do a proper film just inspired by
the game they would have a ready-made
audience particularly in the asian
market so for that reason alone really
i'm completely convinced that after
gears of war gets made the next big game
to be turned into a movie will be zelda
what do you think guys have we got any
hardcore gamers out there are there any
other games that you would love to see
get the big hollywood movie makeover
treatment
or is there some classics you'd like to
see should we get another mario brothers
film you know the first song was
terrible but then you get movies like
say detective pikachu which is a bit of
a guilty pleasure of mine i quite like
that film
just show how a film like that could be
made and could be made well
so get in the comments do you think
that's a good idea a film like that to
be honest would have to really embrace
the silliness or it just wouldn't work
um but embrace your silliness in a
better way than it did from the original
by the way you can support the channel
and become a fully fledged sidetracker
please hit the join button and if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification hit
all of the buttons the like buttons
mainly not the dislike button that
doesn't help anyone and that it really
really helps us out and as always please
stay safe i'll see you soon